enfin c'est nathan une petite interview
spéciale si vous voulez bien en la
gauche part dans le seigneur
[Musique]
bien interdits moralité est ce que vous
avez déjà appliquée dans le
porte-monnaie de votre maman quand vous
étiez petit dans le porte-monnaie de ma
maman orange est sûrement dû prendre de
quoi aller acheter à carambar ou et
l'accord de l'huile bâle iii
est ce que vous êtes déjà sortis et que
la copine d'un copain
j'ai beaucoup de copains ouais
un commerçant se trompe à votre avantage
en vous rendant l'âme n'ai voulu fait
remarquer oui tout de suite ça
m'arrivait sam
sam arrive malheureusement souvent je
trouve que les gens comptent de plus en
plus mal si votre côté fils de
commerçants si vous pensez à vos parents
non c'est mon côté n'être j'aime pas
qu'on me rende l'argent tu ne
m'appartient pas c'est pas l'interview
mensonge en a assez non c'est la vérité
vous imaginez un jeu de l'esprit vous
avez un appartement vous possédez un
appartement votre locataire peut plus
payer le loyer c'est un type odieux mais
vraiment odieux il a deux enfants
insupportables voulait foot est dehors
jamais non jeu d'abord je loue pas
d'appartement parce que je
voudrais surtout pas me retrouver dans
ce genre de situation j'aime pas ça et
quand j'étais président de l'office
départemental des hlm c'est à dire 30000
logements dans les hauts-de-seine croyez
moi avant d'expulser
quelqu'un il fallait vraiment qu'on
puisse pas arriver à d'autres solutions
j'ai toujours fait en sorte que les gens
soient relogés soit aidé mis des
enquêteurs me des assistantes sociales
qu'un des piats ou non ses moi je les
fais par conviction
rien d'autre je les fais je n'ai pas
appris et en vue de gérer de gauche si
vous continuez comme ça mais je suis pas
de droite à ceyras couple non non je
sais pas ce que c'est la gauche et la
droite j'étais gaulliste la gauche s'est
partagé quand j'ai beaucoup d'argent
c'est partagé que les autres c'est à
gueuler de payer trop d'impôts toute la
journée parce qu'on sait que certains
réseaux torrent vous savez aujourd'hui
je sais pas j'ai pas la presse alors ça
a dû changer ça a dû beaucoup changer la
gauche partagée comment vous avez dit
partager partager le pouvoir non en ce
moment en vous cite à l'ordre du mérite
pour un acte héroïque en fait vous
n'avez pas fait vous étiez là quand ça
s'est produit et vous c'est pas vous qui
avait sauvé le môme de se faire écraser
est ce que vous dit rien vous prenez la
médaille au contraire je la remets à
celui qu'il a fait pour moi je le crois
moi aussi voilà merci il faut être sûr
de ne rien rater le in auditive abonnez
vous il m'était impossible ou